it could be a day like any other on anza
bus town square as locals taken the
Summer Sun the camera teams from around
the world have descended on the small
boveri in town drawn by the violence of
Germany's first suicide bombing many
residents seem wary of the attention and
fear it could provoke more attacks they
tell us they just want life to get back
to normal add of hangs near the site of
the blasts an appeal for reconciliation
but the memories of Sunday's attack
remain fresh the city was already in
mourning after Munich smash shooting the
town halls flags draped in black but few
expected similar violence would soon
strike here you're still scared you
don't know what other people are
thinking and if the attacker had help or
of someone else is planning another
attack I'm physician you just have to
accept that you can't be safe anywhere
the children are afraid my daughter was
terrified the evening had happened she
was early sorry I work with refugees at
my job in a kindergarten we have a lot
of refugee children and I've only had
positive experiences I'm not going to
let some psycho ruin my opinion of the
refugees I won't start to hate reads
this sign a message to the refugees who
call ins ba home around six hundred
asylum seekers live here including some
in the converted hotel that was home to
Sunday's attacker
a first step towards normality the owner
of the wine bar that was struck by the
blast welcomes his first guests most a
Regulus who've come to show their
support one was by tomorrow you have to
keep going you have to believe in the
good in life and peace and love and keep
looking forward customers are slowly
returning to the scene of the attack as
life in ansbach gets back to normal